hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game it was suggested to me on
twitter by vitam patel so thank you for
that
and it's a game from the uh indian
qualifier satoru man versus
um and the two winners of the indian
qualifier or the two uh two of the top
players who qualify will be uh entering
the champions chester to join everyone
else uh in
in that great tournament so this is a
really violent a violent game i i don't
remember the last time we've had
such a great one and it's a really a
great way to you know
start your weekend so to say uh for some
of you
and uh it's i don't know i don't know
what
what to say more about this game than to
just show it to you but uh
you you know we are going to have a
great time
checking out this game but one of the
players here uh most certainly did not
have a great time so the the
format is pretty similar to the
champions chester
only here they only play one match not
two matches uh so it's first
four games of rapid chess and if the
game uh or if the match
ends in a tie then two more blaze games
are played and i imagine if
those two end in a draw then an
armageddon game is being played
so the four rapid games uh after they
have been played uh
they didn't yield a winner uh and now
they have to play two
blitz games so let's see what happens in
this game as it's uh
well it's uh i don't know if you if you
remember uh i i would
compare this game to the kashdan
immortal maybe
but it's uh you know it's it's uh uh up
up there uh
you guys be the judge of that so as
tourman with the white pieces opens with
e4 we have e5 knight to f3 knight to c6
and the bishop to b5 now some people
don't even try to go for the evans
gambit anymore
we have a6 uh morpheus defense attacking
the bishop here we have bishop to a4 and
now
knight to f6 so nothing out of the
ordinary here we have castles and now
bishop the c5 going for the
so called our kangaskh's or the the
newer kungusk's uh
setup uh we have c3 in the black castles
here and now the
most uh common idea here for white is
just the strike in the center with d4
and there isn't a top player who hasn't
had this position with the white pieces
and played it carlson had it nakamura
had it wastely so headed uh arun had it
kara can had it uh maxime vacherol graph
had
a neil's granddale use had it so uh it's
and many many more
so it's a very common position but here
we don't have d4 but rather d3 it's not
a new move but it is a
uh well not not one played as often uh
we have b5
attacking the bishop bishop goes back
and now d6 preparing to develop the
light square bishop
uh we have bishop to g5 pinning the
knight here and this is now a great pin
because the pawn is on d6 and the
bishop cannot go back to help out with
the defense so then the only way to
unpin
uh would be just to play h6 and g5 and
this is in fact
exactly what black goes for so h6 bishop
to h4
and now g5 with bishop back to g3 and
now bishop to b6 a standard idea in such
such lines in the future you might have
some support for c5 and
the bishop will not be attacked if white
at some point pushes d4
so here white plays a4 and this position
has been reached before
no moves are rook to a1 knight b to d2
just nice developing moves but here we
have a4
and it is now as of move 12 that we have
a completely new game
and the black has to decide what to do
here so you you could try many ideas
like knight a5 go after the bishop you
could advance the pawn to b4
or you could play rook to b8 and there
are similar
lines where it's okay for black to
sacrifice this pawn for example knights
to a3
sorry knight to a3 and then you could
even give up this pawn
but as you'll see here this will not be
the case because after captures captures
and
knight to a3 black just goes knight to
h7
and this is now a problem for white
because black is ready to start pushing
those king side pawns
and grabbing the pawn that will only
help black
in doing so so for example here h5 h4 is
coming
you have to make some room for the
bishop not g4 right away first
we're going to push h4 get the bishop to
h2 and then we're going to push
gt4 and it's uh well it's a pretty
uh crazy attack uh happening here for
black and it's a blitz game
if you don't notice you don't want to be
caught off guard by black so instead we
have d4 here
but this doesn't really change black's
plans and black continues in the exact
same way so here h5
we have h3 and now h4 pushing the bishop
back and now
g4 so what do you play here you have to
capture otherwise if you allow black to
capture the the g file opens up and then
it's trouble
so h captures with bishop captures now
the knight cannot move
uh the queen to d3 now immediately
unpinning
and asking black what do you play here
so here black plays e
captures on d4 and now c captures on d4
doesn't work because we simply remove
the defender of the d4 pawn for example
captures captures knight captures on d4
and that's just a terrible terrible
position for white
black already grabbed the pawn black is
on the attack you have a beautiful
bishop here that you have to be careful
knight can come to e2 with
check queen is coming to g5 so it's a a
really really tough position for white
to play so instead after e captures on
d4 we have knight captures on d4
uh but now knight to e5 again an
excellent outpost for the knight because
it cannot be captured if you capture it
then the knight is lost uh
the queen on d3 is undefended so here
instead after knight to e5
we have queen to e3 uh queen to d2 was
the last
real attempt for for white but here
queen to e3 is played
and now this simply doesn't work and uh
this is uh well only the first pause the
video moment
uh that we will have in this video we're
gonna have three of them
uh so feel free to pause the video here
and try to find the winning idea for
black
while i give you a couple of seconds
uh so for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting such a
such a nice move and why the queen on e3
isn't as good as the queen on d2
and for those who just want to enjoy the
show it's c5
and now what do you play here your
knight is under attack and once you move
the knight
this pawn is coming to c4 the reason why
i say it's
uh winning and why it's almost
not winning or rather it almost is
winning is because if
this wasn't the blitz game and the white
hat all the time in the world white
could come up with a
uh sort of a defensive idea and i'm
gonna show it because i know you guys
enjoy them
for example we're gonna play knight d
captures on b5
then allow c4 and then okay now the
queen is under attack and the bishop is
under attack
the queen will move queen f4 c captures
on b3
and now we're gonna eliminate the d6
pawn this is the idea
and now after our knight is captured
we're just going to capture the bishop
here that's the stuff
the queen will be uh the queen is also
under attack and
this is uh this comes with check so here
we're going to capture
bishop captures and now uh we trade down
into a very nice end game the rook is
under attack for example rook k8
bishop captures an f8 knight captures
and now we get
this position where uh black is of
course uh
better black has two pieces for a rook
and it's very hard for white
to find any sort of a plan if you try to
activate with something like knight to
c4
there's always bishop captures on f2 and
such ideas where you cannot capture
because the rook on a1 would be hanging
so you'd have to move the king
and then captures captures and then we
have this end game where it's uh
rook and the knight against the bishop
knight and knight and the black would of
course be better here
where whether black would win this it's
hard to say but
that's why i say that c5 is winning but
take it with it with a grain of salt
but okay this is a blitz game so of
course we cannot uh
expect uh to see such ideas so bishop
captures an e5 was played
and now d captures an e5 you don't want
to capture on d4 because then bishop
captures on d4 and now it's white who's
better
so instead we have pawn captures bishop
here and now
knight the c6 attacking the queen and
the rook here
but harsha just moves the queen and he
plays queen to f6
now attacking the knight and what do you
play here c4 is still a threat attacking
the bishop the queen
the knight is under attack so what can
you play here there is one sneaky idea
bishop to d1 but even that is
insufficient because black just trades
for example captures
now white captures on b8 and after
bishop back to g4
uh now what do you play here uh you of
course play
c4 so you of course play c4 prevent
black from pushing c4 and now after b
for attacking knight let's say knight b5
and then you capture the
the knight on b8 but it's still a much
much better position for black and the
white
wouldn't really stand a chance here but
it was it was
in the position and i know how much you
guys enjoy that so here
knight captures and b8 was played a wide
set all right i have to capture the rook
and hope for the best
uh but now uh even without pausing the
video i know you guys
uh know what to play here and that of
course none of you were
uh probably going for rook captures on
b8
but instead c4 and this is the the good
stuff so congratulations as i know all
of you found it
now the bishop is under attack the queen
is under attack and
the knight is under attack so what can
you play here
uh well you have to save the queen uh
there's you know
everything else can fall and will fall
but here queen to d2 was played and now
again not grabbing any material but
improving the position first
rook to d8 first get that rook into the
game and then we're going to continue
well maybe grabbing material maybe not
so here queen to e1
and now again not going for material but
knight to g5 and this is just unplayable
now for white
uh white has no good moves the bishops
are completely slicing the position in
half the the queen is here the rook is
here
everything is ready to attack the pawn
is ready to
uh to be pushed to h3 so
uh not not uh not a lot of good moves
bishop to d1 was played in the game
but now uh you are black for the last
time feel free to pause the video and
win this game
uh in the quickest possible way while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those who were able to do it
congratulations on finding any winning
move
uh even knights the h3 the winning move
queen to f4 is a winning move so a lot
of winning moves here but
the most straightforward one uh is uh
rook
captures on the one uh this just attacks
the queen now you've
grabbed material and you have to react
to this rook captures on d1 was played
but here we have just knight to f3 with
check
and now what you play the king and queen
are in check a nice royal fork here
uh you either move the king and then
well you again get
checkmated and you might even lose the
queen or you captured the knight which
was played in the game g captures
but then bishop captures on f3 and it
was in this position
on move 30 that's the tournament
resigned to the game
and as he also lost the other one in the
blitz section it is uh
uh bahara kotiharsha who proceeds uh to
the
uh higher parts of the competition and
just so i don't forget i'm gonna show
you the standings but first why did he
resign well
there's simply no move here for white
queen g5 check for example followed by
queen to g2 checkmate
and there is nothing you can do to avoid
this if you try something like king h2
to maybe bring the rook to g1
then we don't allow it simply queen f4
check and it's the the same idea king h3
we're gonna go queen g4 check king h2
and now queen to g2 will be checkmate
so whatever you do here there's really
no no defense against uh
uh well with best uh with best moves
from white it's checkmate in four
so so i don't forget as uh we're
probably going to show some more
uh games uh from this uh from this
competition as
uh well especially if they will be as
nice as this one
uh so sorry about that uh
it's uh a cross table from chess 24 so
let me just
enlarge that a little bit uh
there we go uh so these are the
standings of uh
the uh the quarter the quarterfinals
uh so as you can see uh adiban uh
defeated defeated
gosh then we have pragyananda defeated
murli kartakin
uh we have uh aravinda defeated
harikadranawali then we have surah
shekhar ganguly defeated
vishak then we have anika sarin who lost
to aryun a tough break for nihal as i
know a lot of you were
were really rooting for him satturaman
got eliminated by bahra kotiharsha
as we've seen in this game gurkish
defeated gupta
and uh here we have uh the the last
pairing
defeated krishnan sasekiran so there
were there were some
upsets uh but it's always you know great
when that happens and it's
not a gm exclusive event there i think
there are two international masters also
playing here so we'll see
uh who wins uh and who will qualify for
the champions chess tour
so really an awesome game thank you vita
patel for suggesting it to me and it's
really
really a wild one so hope you guys
enjoyed it as well and hope you will
have you know
hope your weekend starts better than
this game did for for satturaman
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it i would like to thank bruce
cotman
andrew linder jared mills stefan sela
and robert audio for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage
of the morphe saga checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day